Now I'd like to show you a series of examples that basically best
showcase what the shutter speed does to a image that's captured on the sensor.
Remember again,
the amount of time the sensor is exposed to the light is the way,
the best way to kind of see what's going to be registered on the sensor.
Here we see an example of an image captured with a shutter speed of one second.
Of course, what comes out of it is a whole lot of blurry streaks of the water.
Here I'm showing you basically an image of a waterfall and
it's being exposed at different shutter speeds shown here.
So it starts of with one second all the way to
different shutter speeds of one-third, one-thirtieth, one-two-hundredth.
So this is one second, one-third, one-thirtieth, one-two-hundredth,
and one-eight-hundredth speed.
So again, you can see the different details when this happens.
We see, basically, water, and the water fountain becoming streaking.
Or becoming much more crisper.
So you can streaks of water, blurry water, and really crisp images there.
So the amount of time the sensor is exposed to light is
basically what allows you to have these different effects.
Usually these amounts are denoted by fractions of a second.
We saw various examples.
It could be 1/2000 would be a very fast shutter, or 1/1000.
All the way to even how long you want to keep it open.
You can actually keep a shutter open for 30 seconds.
And sometimes most cameras, in fact,
have a version called bulb where basically if the shutter's open for
the exact time that you've actually pressed the shutter and released it.
And basically now you kind of see how the effects of motion blur to streaks
are captured by a photographer who wants to control these types of parameters.
Another way of looking at the same thing is here I'm basically showing an
example of a waterfall again at a faster shutter speed of 1/125th of a second.
Of course when I go to a slower shutter speed,
one-tenth of a second you can start seeing a lot more of the streaks.
And even more blurriness and
streak kind of shows here with one-half of a second.
Another example, the same category.
Still sharp of this thing, basically shows each and every petal.
Very crisp, increase it and now I start seeing a little bit more.
And of course I really have a much wider or
much more open shutter then you'll see everything blurring.